طفل الملهى الليلي يصدم العراقيين
والعالم يودع الاسطوره البرازيليه
رغم الانتقادات اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
اذا اكيد يا جماعه خبر انضمام رونالدو
وانتقاله للعاصمه السعوديه الرياض مفعوله
ساري وما بيخلص فلاعب فريق النصر الاول
لكره القدم راح يوصل اليوم عند الساعه
11:00 مساء للرياض العاصمه السعوديه وذلك
بطياره خاصه راحت كلهم من مدريد برفقه
عائلته ومجموعه من مستشاريه الاعلاميين
والقانونيين وسط طبعا تسديدات امنيه كبيره
خلونا نشوف سواء اخر فيديو من رونالدو وهو
بالطياره
سيصوم
كثير كبير ومفاجات اكبر راح تكون بانتظار
رونالدو بالرياض والاهم انه نادي النصر
السعودي حدد مكان وزمان الاحتفال بانضمام
الاسطوره بكره الثلاثاء السابعه مساء
بساحه النصر في ملعب مرسول بارايك وقتها
راح تكون جماهير النصر بانتظار الحدث
المنتظر لاستقبال لاعب النصر كريستيانو
رونالدو مصادر لصحيفه الرياضيه السعوديه
قالت كمان انه رونالدو راح يخضع بكره لكشف
طبي قبل طلب بطاقته دوليه اللي بتعطيه حق
المشاركه مع النصر في المباريات الجايه
اشارت المصادر هذه نفسها انه كريستيانو
راح يكون متواجد باحد الفنادق الشهيره
داخل الرياض حتى يتم تجهيز مقر سكن الدائم
من ثلاثه ايام غياب الموت الاسطوره
البرازيلي ولاعب كره القدم المخضرم بيليه
عن عمر ناهز 82 عاما نقل ناس بطل العالم
لثلاث مرات لملعب نادي نادي سانتوس في
البرازيل لتقام مراسم وداعه اما الجنازه
فرح تكون بكره واجتمع الاف المشجعين في
ساحه الملعب لاستقبال موكب بطل كره القدم
يلعب
يمكن انه ينعمل بحق هيك انسان عمل تاريخ
لنفسه ولبده ولا كره القدم عالميا صحيفه
ديسن البريطانيه قالت انه الراحل اختار
مقبره خارجه عن المقلوب لحتى يدفن فيها
وما راح تكون تحت الارض بل تحديدا في
الطابق التاسع من مبنى فخم يطل على ملعب
سانتوس المكان اللي تالق فيه وحظيه باكبر
النجاحات في عالم كره القدم الصحيفه
البريطانيه كشفت انه بيليه امضاء كثير من
الوقت لاختيار مكانه الاخير وانه اختار
انه يدفن في الطابق التاسع من المقبره
العموديه تكريما لوالده دوندينو اللي كان
لاعب كره القدم كذلك واعتاد انه يرتدي
القميص رقم تسعه دائما كثير تفاصيل محيطه
بمراسم الدفن ما زالت سريه مشاهدينا لكن
الصحيفه البريطانيه قالت انه المعلوم حتى
الان انه تابوت سيكون ذهبيا وستكون على
جوانب العديد من المنحوتات لصور بلاي
الايقونه
[موسيقى]
فاصل قصير مشاهدينا نتابع بعده تفاعلكم
اقامها
اهلا فيكم من جديد نشر اي محتوى على مواقع
التواصل هو بحداته مسؤوليه لازم كلنا نعرف
حجمها لانه ببساطه اي حد هاي الايام بينشر
صور ومقاطع فيديو غير صحيحه ممكن تنتشر
على نطاق واسع عن شو عم نحكي بالضبط
وقالوا انها بتوثق ظاهره غريبه بتحدث في
الحرم المكي لاول مره وهي تساقط الثلج
داخل الحرم خلونا نشوف الفيديو مع بعض
وبعدها بنحكي عن مدى صح هذا الخبر
الو الو
[موسيقى]
الفيديو اللي شفته اعزائي انتشر كالنار في
الهشيم على مواقع التواصل عن الحاله الجدل
مش طبيعيه بس الفيديو مفبرك وغير صحيح
وهذا اللي اكده المتحدث باسم المركز
الوطني للارصاد الجويه السعوديه حسين
القحطاني اللي قال انه الفيديو المتداول
لا تساقط الثلوج على المسجد الحرام غير
صحيح ومعالج بمؤثرات اضافيه
[موسيقى]
نيجي لاخبار المشاهير في قصص المشاهير
بمصر تحديدا ما بتخلص ومن المشاهير
للاعلاميين واحنا مكملين فبعد ما دخل رجل
الاعمال المصري نجيب سويرس في سيجال مع
اعلاميين مصريين بعد تعليقه على صوره
مزيفه ساخره لعدد من الاعلاميين يدقون
الطبول نشر صوير الصوره معدله من حساب
مغرب مجهول بتجمع ست اعلاميين على راسهم
عمرو اديب بيحملوا طبله ليقوم نجيب سويرس
بتغريدها مره اخرى على حسابه وكتب عليها
في واحد ناقص واكيد يا جماعه عمرو اديب ما
سكت وقتها واعتبر انه اعاده تغريد نجيب
سويرس للصوره بتحمل اشاره مباشره واتهام
له ولا زملاءه كمان بالتطبيل لا يرد عمرو
اديب بتعليق على تغريد تسوي راس احنا ما
كسبناش ان التطبيل قد ما انت كسبت من
تطويلك يا نجيب جايز تطويلنا كان له اصوات
انما تطويلك كان له ابراج ودولارات
ويخساره وعجبي عموما هيك بلشت القصه بس
الجديده بالموضوع انه تغريده تغريده
انتشرت بتحمل خبر اقامه سوي راس حفله
اعتذار من الاعلاميين على الاساءه الاساءه
لهم رجع طبعا الاخذ والرد في هذا الموضوع
بس سال احد المغردين حول رئيس سواراس في
نبا اعتذار ولا الاعلاميين خلال الحفل
الخاص في الجونه فرنسا سؤال كلام فارغ
على ما يبدو اعزائي انه بهذه الايام بايام
هادي ما عاد في شيء غريب ممكن انه يصير
هالمره من العراق وتحديدا من ملهى ليلي
بالعاصمه بغداد ظهرت طفل ما بيتجاوز عمره
12 سنه بمقطع فيديو عم يتمايل ويرقص
ويلقي بالاموال على احدى الراقصات خلونا
نشوف
[موسيقى]
الله
هذا الصراف
[موسيقى]
الصراف الرياضه
اخر مكان بالعالم
القوانين العراقيه الغير مطبقه بتمنع دخول
الاطفال والقصيرين للنوادي الليليه ولا
الملاهي بس لحظه يا جماعه في شيء عن جد
انا شخصيا مش قادره استوعب وهو تصرف
السلطات العراقيه لانها طالب طالبتدا مدير
الشرطه المجتمعيه في العراق
العميد غالب العطيه طالب في منشور على
فيسبوك بمساعدته بالضبط في معرفه اسم
الطفل اللي ظهر في مقطع الملهى الليلي
يعني عنجد الشرطه العراقيه رايحه تدور على
الطفل وتركه صاحب الملح بالاساس لدخول
قاصرين
يعني بصراحه الموضوع مضحك ومبكي في ذات
الوقت
عموما في شيء ابدا ما بنقدر نجاهله ولا
نقدر نتخطى اصلا وهو كثير معروف بالنسبه
لها كثير ناسه وهو سيطره الميليشيات
الولائيه على الملاهي الليليه في العراق
الموضوع هذا يا جماعه مش جديد فمن وقت ما
هو الاقتصاد النظام الايراني بسبب
العقوبات الامريكيه بدات المليشيات
التابعه لايران في البحث عن مصادر تمويل
جديده وقتها بالفعل انتشره تقارير بتحكي
عن وجود نوع من الحمايه مقابل المال
بيفرضها عناصر من المليشيات على الملاهي
الليليه ودور القمار ومحل محلات بيع
مشروبات كحوليه في العراق وحتى نكون
واضحين اهداف المليشيات مش الحمايات اكيد
فهي اهداف غسيل الاموال والتهريب والاجتار
بالبشر واللي هو مش غريب على ايران في
العراق
على كل حال عن هاي الحادثه المتكرره للاسف
في العراق معنا من اربيل الكاتب الصحفي
عماد باجلان اهلا بك استاذ عماد معنا
استاذ عماد خليني ابدا اللي حكيته قبل شوي
في المقدمه
المشكله صفت هلا بالطفل اللي عمره 12 سنه
اللي ما بيعرف شو الصح من الغلط ولا اصحاب
ملهى ليلي ومن يدير وملهى ليلي بهذا الشكل
وبيسمحوا له قاصرين همم يدخلوا يعني
يعملوا اشياء بهذا الشكل وشجعوهم على ما
يبدو
بدايه سيده الفاضله تحيه لك والمشاهده
قناه العربيه الكرام بدون ادنى الشك
المدير الشرطه المجتمعيه لا يستطيع القاء
القبض على صاحب الملهى لين صاحب الماليه
لديه شركاء وهذه وهؤلاء الشركاء همم على
الغالب يكونون منتمين لاحزاب متنفذه في
بغداد هذه الدور القمار والملاهي كلهم
لديهم همم يعني اقول حمايه من احزاب
متنفذه حاكمه في بغداد فهنا الشرطه لا
تستطيع النيل منهم وقد سمعنا من قبل همم
ايام همم يعني اقول قبل القران ايضا اصبح
هناك انتهاكات والشرطه تحركت واصحاب المحل
همم افرج عنهم وهمم يعني غرقت القضيه يعني
سيدتي مع مع نشاهده الان في العراق للاسف
يعني نتيجه تراكمات وهمم تراكمات ونتائج
الحروب التي خاضها العراق
فاصبح الطفل الحلقه
عرفي المجتمع العراقي يذهب الى المدرسه
يتعرض للعنف يذهب الى السوق يتعرف يتعرض
الى التحرش يرجع الى البيت يتعرض الى
التعنيف الاسري والى اخره لماذا لان هناك
همم غياب لقوانين راضعه وقوانين حمايه
حقوق الطفل لذلك نقابه الابوين يعني هذا
منظر غير مقبول لطفل يعني ووو من غير
المنطقي انه النوم الطفل على هذا الشيء من
يوم اهله من لوم القائمين على همم
الليلي والمسؤولين عن هذا الانحدار اصلا
سيدتي الطفل اصبح الحلقه الافضل اضعف
واصبح الضحيه في المجتمع العراقي يعني بكل
جوارب من كل الجوان ناحيتي عن مساله
التربيه اييه قبل في العراق كان لدينا
التربيه والتعليم للاسف الان لا يوجد
تربيه ويوجد تعليم فاشل فقط اما بالنسبه
للاهالي بالنسبه للابوين فهذه تعتمد على
ثقافاتهم على بيئتهم واصبح تغيير الشامل
في المجتمع العراقي منذ منذ عقدين او
ثلاثه على اقل تقدير في مساله التربيه
ومساله همم
العين يقول القيم الاخلاق الى اخره
لانه غياب الرقابه وغياب القوانين الرائعه
وغياب همم دعيني اقول
الحكومه ومواقف الحكومه وغياب دور
المنظمات المجتمع المدني التي كانت الى حد
ما توعي الناس بعكس الحكومات التنفيذيه
ولكن لان
ايضا التحدث بالتجاره والادعيه يقول همم
الاموال وتركت ايضا هذا الجانب مساله
التوعيه والتوعيه الطفل خاصه فلذلك الوضع
في العراق بالنسبه للطفل المزري ووضع همم
دعيني اقول يعني سوداوي الى ابعد الحدود
ناهي عن انه كما ذكرت انه هناك همم قسم من
الميليشيات واحزاب متنفذه هم من يعني يقول
يعتمدون على همم اقتصاد واقتصاد ليس بقليل
من هذه الدور الملاهي والقمرات والقمار
وهذه الاماكن همم يعني لا احد يستطيع لن
نقابات ولا همم
ولا الشرطه المجتمعيه ووضع احد همم هذه
القوانين والسلوكيات انه يمنع الطفل بدون
18 دخول هذه المعركه ان هناك في الكثير من
هذه الدور همم فتيات يرقص في عمر الرابع
عشر والثالثه عشر والخامسه عشر ايضا لم
تبلغ ا ا دعيني اقول السن القانوني ولا
احد يستطيع محاسبه اصحاب المحل لانهم كما
ذكرت همم شركاء مع ناس متنفدين في هذا
البلد للاسف
بصراحه في تناقض كبير بحيث انه بنشوف
فيديوهات مثل هاي بنشوف فيديوهات لقتل همم
فتيات بتاع همم الشرف يعني همم ومنلاقي
كمان بانه يعني من همم يعني همم
يحاول انه يروج لمثل هذه المناظر اللي
عملنا بنشوفها وبيحمي القائمين عليها هم
نفسهم اذرع مثلا ايران اللي بتسوق نفسها
على انه هي حما- حمايه الاخلاق وحاميه
الدين بين ما بتحكم على همم يعني فتيات
ايرانيات بالموت او تقتلهم لانه مش لابسين
الحجاب ولكن تسمح بمثل هذا هذه المناظر
يعني في المناطق اخرى
يعني للاسف نحن لا نعتب على الدول بقدر
مانعاتب على الاشخاص الذين بيدهم السلطات
واشخاص الذين لديهم السلطه
والحزبيه كانت السلطه القضائيه والسلطه
التنفيذيه ابناء البلد الذين يعضون النظر
عن هكذا اماكن وهكذا سلوكيات في حين
القانون العراقي كما ذكرتي واضح يمنع بعد
يعني هذه السلوكيات غير مطبق هنا هنا نقطه
هنا هنا
مربط الفرس انه لا يطبق وترينا ان هناك
قوانين تضر تضر يعني يضر بالشعب العراقي
ويطبق ولا ولا
يعملون على تغييره ولكن القوانين التي
تحمي الطفل
وترعى همم يعني همم
اخلاق المجتمع العراقي لا يطبقها هذا ما
جعل هذا يستفحل وينتشر في همم دعيني اقول
هكذا ما كانت في المراقص والبارات
والملاهي ودور القمار لانه لا يوجد عقابه
ولا ردع ولا دور ايجابي
قله التمويل من ايران الان في ظروف
الراهنه طبعا بعد العقوبات الامريكيه
عليها بدات تترجم على الارض بانه
الميليشيات التابعه لايران في العراق بدات
تبحث عن مصادر تمويل اخرى للاسف اغلبها
غير نظيف
من الطبيعي جدا اي دوله اي دوله انا قلتها
قبل الان اي دوله تكون مكاني ايران ولدها
لديها ذراع ولديها ولا مطلق من دوله جاره
انت تفعل ما تريد يعني خاصه عليها ضغط واا
حصار اقتصادي همم يعني كبير فلذلك باي
طريقه انه الاموال اذا تعود الى ايران
ولكن المشكله ليست في ايرانيين وفي
سياستهم وتفكيرهم بالقدر مع المشكله لدى
العراقيين الذين لديهم ولا مطلق لبلد جار
وليس لديهم ولاء لبلدهم هنا هنا المشكله
هنا هنا المشكله ولكن انه همم
ايران ايران كيف لها ان تستطيع ان تعمل كل
هذا في داخل العراقي وهي دوله اذ لم يكن
لديها عراقيين عراقيين هم اذ هم ايران
وهؤلاء العراقي يعتبرون همم ايران بلدهم
الام وولعهم لايران اكثر بلدهم فهنا العتب
ليس على ايران بقدر ما هو العتب على همم
اذرع ايران في العراق اي كانت ال- ال-
الطرق سوف تعمل ايران لكسب الاموال للتنفس
اقتصاديا على اقل تعبير شكرا
كان معانا من اربيل
عام 2023 يبدو انها فايته وبقوه على كثير
من المشاهير بالعالم مثل ما كنا بنعرف
ليله راس السنه هي ليله المفروض تكون
سعيده وحلوه لانه بنكون على موعد مع بدايه
جديده وصفحه بيضاء مثل ما بيقولوا بس لحتى
نكون واضحين الليله هذه ما كانت منيحه
ابدا على ملكه جمال افريقيا السابقه وحيده
قروج اللي كانت بالجزائر عم تحتفل ويبدو
انه بدايه صفحتها بهذه السنه الجديده راح
تكون مليئه بالتوام وراء القضبان عموما
السلطات الامنيه بالجزائر العاصمه القات
القبض على قروش ليله راس السنه وبيحسب
وسائل الاعلام الجزائريه تم القبض على
قروش بعد ما تم اقتحام منزلها والعثور على
كميه كبيره من مخدر الكوكايين ومبالغ
ماليه ضخمه الموضوع اكيد ما خلص لانه
السلطات حاله المتهمه الى تحقيق في
الواقعه وافضل تحقيق الى قرار بحب سمو
مؤقتا مش بس هيك زوج المتهم اللي كان خارج
المنزل وقت عمليه اقتحام قوات الامن هرب
بعد ما عرف بخبر اعتقال زوجته وفي شيء
كثير مهم كمان مش لازم من سانه شقيق وحيد
القروج هو حاليا كمان بالسجن بعد ادانته
في قضيه مخدرات
وهيك مشاهدينا وصلنا على ختام حلقه
تفاعلكم لهذا اليوم بشكركم على حسن
المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]